[Music]  he brought sexy back in 2006 he was  dapper in his suit and tie in 2013 and  now Justin Timberlake is funky  futuristic and filthy like never before  [Music]  yep that's JT playing a modern inventor  presenting his latest creation to the  world a humanoid robot he starts out  timid but through Timberlake's coaching  he gets his swag on dancing with ladies  and eventually things get well filthy  [Music]  2018 is off to a huge start for  Timberlake dropping his fifth studio  album man of the woods on February 2nd  just 2 days later on February 4th he'll  take the stage during the Pepsi Super  Bowl halftime show Timberlake's wife  Jessica Biel told ET in October she's  just as excited as we are I guess I  could be a little bit biased but I think  he puts on the best show of anybody and  I think that's that's a fact anyway so  I'm just excited for him to have you  know a really incredible place to you  know to perform and you know play some  some great stuff  [Music]